u.s healthcare officials cautioned that
without a miracle this was a moment
impossible to avoid the fact that a
large number of our coveted
hospitalizations
are incidental
really reflects the level of community
spread of omicron
more than 147 thousand americans are in
hospital including 4 400 kids it's a
pandemic high running head first into
record-breaking case numbers we have
hundreds of doctors and nurses now that
have covid and are isolating because of
that i'm so sorry to be calling you like
this and adding to the burnout for
hospital staff a death toll which still
hovers at sixteen hundred per day
the rampant spread of omicron now
prompting drug makers to act i don't
know if we will need it i don't know if
and how will be used but we'll be ready
pfizer is set to produce 100 million
doses of an omicron specific vaccine
unsure how long its booster protection
lasts the ever changing messaging over
vaccines has only worked to deepen
political battles during this pandemic
you are making a catastrophic epidemic
for your political gain
on tuesday health experts pushed back on
personal attacks from elected officials
while working to clean up criticism over
evolving guidance this is the right
guidance for what we currently know
about transmission and the real world
circumstances we currently face
meanwhile as the u.s struggles to
contain its outbreaks americans are now
being advised to avoid traveling to
canada due to soaring cases a move
facing blowback from bordertown
lawmakers even with canada already
cautioning against all non-essential
travel cdc's decision to advise against
travel to canada is based solely on
metrics but even with the united states
faring far worse than any other country
on earth there's no appetite for new
restrictions on domestic travel reggie
shakini global news washington